is Linda Benham she's gonna tell us
about cloud made simple with serverless
Python let's give her a round of
applause can you guys hear okay perfect
so my name is Belinda Venna
I'm a developer advocate and software
developer and idea right now
my current focus is on both cloud and
serve her this prior to this role I was
a software developer on the idea pop
functions project which has made some
type of Apache okra oh it's kind of
coming in based on top of Apache obelisk
so who here has heard of server list um
is anyone using server list in their
projects okay so less people anyone like
projects and production with server list
okay so same people awesome
today we're going to talk about some of
the benefits of server list and then
we'll also check out a real life use
piece and then I'll show you guys a
quick demo of running some Python code
on us
so um let's say I've been working on a
project and I'm ready to play my code
outs of it out to the top in the past me
or someone else on my company might have
needed the purchase bare-metal servers
to run my application on um you have to
manage those security updates for the
servers and saw all the required
software and keep the hardware up today
then virtual machines came into the
picture right we were able to let
someone else like Amazon and Rackspace
search and manage those machines for us
when we just get a virtual machine to
run our application on you still have to
manage the operating system and the
software dependencies of your
application but you didn't need to
physically own or house those servers
anymore even more recently we've had
Patino's enter the scene where we're
only managing the application code and
it's dependencies we package everything
up into a container we give a container
to the pot to be running so that many
things a lot easier but we're still
managing some of the infrastructure we
need a manager on runtime and our own
application dependencies building a
container to run your application on is
still somewhat manual process that could
still be abstracted away so software
developers really need to focus on that
core business project and not get
distracted by infrastructure managing
our configuration and these abstractions
are ultimately why it's server lists or
functions and service offerings are
promising you so that execution
environment where the code is provided
for me as a developer and my code can
just be run and in response to events or
response to actions that I care about so
I should know I'm positing this as an
evolution but all these models are still
available today and they might even
still be the right choice depending on
what problem you're trying to solve or
what your requirements are I'm still
notice on the x-axis it says decreasing
concern over your stack implementation
but it's also decreasing control so if
there's a security vulnerability or an
environment update that you need to make
you have to wait for the platform
provider to make that required
environment update so if you need that
additional control one of the others
might still be the right option for you
[Music]
so I think this isn't really just
another nice way to visualize the
increasing levels of abstraction so as
we're moving through each of the
deployment models we're seeing less and
less that the end user is responsible
for so on the far left we have unfriend
where you have your own machines and
you're managing everything and then we
go through infrastructure as a service
platform as a service and then
ultimately function does the service
where you literally only write manage
and deal with functions so these
changing deployment models have also
affected how we write and think about
our application we used to write code as
these big monolithic applications the
entire application gets deployed as one
unit and interesting introducing any new
code changes needs a completely new
deployment of the full application even
if you're only changing one or two lines
so from there we move the more to this
microservices paradigm we started to
break the monolithic obligation into
various services that are communicating
with each other over restful api store
application for example you might have a
micro service that manages the accounts
for your users one for placing orders
and what
energy interactions with your shipping
company so you can deploy each of those
microservices either as an application
on a lake pad solution like a platform
as a service solution or maybe a void
each one of those micro services
engineer own containers and then finally
as we move more towards assumptions the
service model there's been further
decoupling and shrinking of the size of
the unit of code so instead of creating
micro services we can literally just
write functions that we want to deploy
to the cloud and each of those functions
have the goal of doing one thing and
doing that one thing really well perhaps
in reaction to a particular event so as
I said serverless promises they you can
just spend your time writing a business
logic that has a direct positive impact
to your users and not focus on that
configuration or management of views
even though it's called server list yes
there are servers but the idea is you
don't have to see them or deal with them
so from a developer's perspective the
functions of the service platform is
going to provide a runtime and an
execution environment for the code that
they're writing so you just write the
code and then the service pot farm runs
it for you in the cloud on demand and
within milliseconds and this may be
actually abstract it away from you so
you typically won't see it but usually
what's happening under the covers is
that code is ultimately being run on a
container and the cloud providers
environment so one of the goals of
server lists is to provide developers
with scalability out of the box so let's
say that you have a set of api's and
you've represented each of those
we've got endpoints as different
functions maybe you know suddenly your
op gets featured on reddit you have
millions are requests from your UI
Chinese back in 88 endpoints the only
thing that's going to happen is that the
platform will start up in multiple
instances of the backend in your code to
process those requests in parallel and
then kind of gives you a horizontal
scaling for free without any additional
programming or server management from
you three stars about your code scaling
out or up to end instances when it's
required but also scales back down to
zero when it's not being used so what
that means from an app developers
perspective is that you're not paying
for the time that your code is not being
run so you're only charged for the
amount of time that the code is actively
running or doing some work you're no
longer paying for that idle time you
have to do the testing wait for your
particular scenario but this can
actually mean really big cost savings
compared to pocket server up five
hundred percent of the time so it really
just depends on the project depends on
the workload but it can be really good
cost savings other promises most server
list solutions provide support for some
kind of instrument scenario so this is
literally anything where an event
happens and you want to react to that
write some code some examples that maybe
you have a new user who signs up to your
app not results in their information
being stored in your customers database
and then you want to execute some logic
and responses that new database item to
maybe send them a welcome email or do
some processing of
and data you'd like a user uploads an
image to that maybe you want to generate
a thumbnail as soon as that image is
stored in your object store and you can
do other things sentiment analysis on
Texas the user who sent by literally
anything you just want your code to
react to a particular event
so typically serverless platforms are
going to provide that infrastructure for
you to easily react to those events with
your code so many of the cloud pop-ups
offer a number of different services you
can integrate with your applications so
these are things like artificial
intelligence IOT platforms object
storage or databases so think of you
know some of the things you can do if
you connect up with like I'm right now
so the watts of API is or maybe the
Alexa API is from Amazon I'm using those
in conjunction with your application
most of the service solutions provided
by the various cloud providers really
want to make that connection very
seamlessly they're really incentivized
for you to go off and use their other
services right so if you're using their
platform they want to make it super easy
for you to connect up with their various
services so I think as you're looking at
you know maybe moving some workloads
order server list definitely look into
what integrations are provided see what
other services even easily and
seamlessly connect up to and we have to
do so ultimately all of these promises
are trying to achieve this overarching
goal of decreasing to market and that
all its and things to help developers
focus not just business value and their
value to the users and not on
infrastructure or configuration I really
like this quote from server less calm
it says service abstracts away the most
menial parts of building
location leaving developers free to
actually spend their days coding so I
think that's kind of the dream of
serveral is that people are going to
realize so there's a few views he says
there emerging is really a nice fit for
the server life space first one is like
web application backends so you have a
front-end and it's making some calls to
some backup api's each of those
endpoints through api's can be functions
that are created in a service partner a
mobile backends super similar to the web
application use case except the
front-end is mobile Internet of Things
so just because a lot of the service
platforms can help me connect up with
some of some kind of IOT platform on the
providers top schedule tasks so let's
say you maybe have some code that you
want to run once a week or maybe once a
month you can set up a chronological
trigger for that code to be spun out
behind means Wednesdays to run and then
after it finishes it spins back down
you're no longer being charged for those
resources that are being used so you
don't have to have the server up all
week just to do that just to run that
code one suite of conversational
scenarios so this is things like clients
where you maybe want to do some
additional processing on the chats that
are coming through so like maybe
translating the text or filtering out
bad words or doing some other other
processing on that text and then finally
data processing so this is literally
anything where you get that new item in
your data store and you want to react to
that with some kind of processing so
there's gonna be things like
normalizing audio inputs imagery size
address verification anything like that
so today I wanted to quickly check out a
real-life use case on a mobile backend
architecture so you can kind of start to
get an idea for how you might protect
your server list apps so that what you
should want to talk about is called
weather gods this is kind of cool
creative way for people to interact with
the weather I think it's like $2.99 on
the App Store and they have they're just
gonna creative way to interactive
weather so the weather is represented as
various gods so there's like a fire god
for heat there's an ice god for winter
weather water out for rain and
precipitation etc I think there's like
six gods maybe I can't keep up with them
all the users can click through the
various weather events or they can
subscribe to our specific notifications
so I actually used to live here in
Austin so when I was living here I think
it's pretty unlikely that I would
subscribe to notifications for a high UV
since that's basically all the time
it was always high here but downtown
where I live there would sometimes be
flooding issues or sometimes there would
be like hail here so I probably go ahead
and describe to like water God
notification interface live
notifications that's kind of how that
works this is the architecture for how
they did their back end obviously they
have a mobile front-end that interacts
with this back-end which isn't picture
so no actually this is a robbery so each
of the little green functions are the
functions that they created it and I'll
kind of quickly walk you guys through
this and then we'll take
step back to talk about why they chose
surfer listen so the first thing that
happens is they have this chronological
trigger it's going to query a subset of
their users which are stored in a
calculus equal TV and then the group
scanner action is going to determine the
locations and weather conditions that
those particular users are interested in
then the next action is just a weather
checker and that makes a call out to the
weather channel data service parses that
purses in handles the data that it gets
back gets into the right format for
their next action it goes and writes
back into the weather database and then
as weather gets updated into the
database that will trigger a scanner for
each user that's interested in that
particular type of data so let's say a
user is interested in snow in New York
and ranan Austin only those two scanners
are invoked for that particular user the
scanners are run in parallel so that
gives them some performance benefits
of course they're also able to scale up
and back down independently and then
once the skimmer finds interesting data
for the user it'll send a notification
by using the push notification service
so what about this architecture makes it
a really nice fit for server lists
there's a few different points on a
highly integrated platform services so
they were able to really easily consume
some services from their cloud platform
in this case a notification service a
database tons of service and the weather
company data API so those are all pieces
that are out there they don't have so
great they're just consuming some
services they were also be able to
regularly schedule their code to run
every option to a trigger every three
minutes a bunch of their code was
running in reaction to events so they
want to run in the weather trucks when a
new user location is updated they want
to react to new users in their database
and of course whenever there's a new
weather item of interest they want to
react to that as well and then finally I
have the really nice scanner section
where their code could be executed in
parallel and independently so the turn
their users are only interested in rain
and then that range scanner code can be
scaled up independently of other events
alternatively like let's say no one's
interested in a particular weather event
that codes not being called on as
ultimately they're not being charged for
it so finding those elements of your
application where you can really benefit
running in very well and scaling out
independently can make a good use case
for server list for that particular
piece and then the last thing I wanted
to highlight about whether gods in
particular is they didn't actually start
out as a fully serverless back-end like
this they already have their problem
than they realized
okay certain pieces of this would
actually benefit from being run on a
server less platform and so they kind of
transition those elements over piece by
piece as it made sense for them so let's
say you're ready to write your next
service oh how do you get started so you
have some options there's these are some
of the major players in this space and
listed them in alphabetical order so the
first one is as your functions for
Microsoft they have a Python runtime but
it's currently in preview so it hasn't
fully become general availability yet
but I would assume that because it's in
preview there we were heading in that
direction lambda from Amazon supports
Python out of the box
Apache open list so this is an open
source Apache Incubator project and this
would be really nice maybe if you need
something open-source or you want to
host and manage your own instance of a
surrealist platform for the rest of your
company now my gift clock functions is
based on the open list and it's
basically just managed and open managed
and hosted open whisk on a VM cloud and
it also supports my gun out of the box
and this is the one
we'll check out in a demo in a couple of
minutes and finally I know a little less
about it but I think it'll be
interesting to check out Python anywhere
so I did a few minutes just not checking
it out thing with it it seems like it's
a little more focused on web hosting and
education use cases but I think it's
just kind of a good one related check
out so let's take a quick peek at what a
function might look like you can see a
really simple example up here it should
look familiar
it looks like Python code so it's a
straightforward color or function and
it's just gonna check and see if they
got mean constant as a parameter it's
not it will return hello stranger
otherwise it's gonna return hello with
the name that was passed in so for
openness and I gave top functions the
expected input and output is JSON so you
can tie your various functions together
with JSON so let's say you have three
functions in a sequence the first one
output some JSON that would be then
input for the next one
that'll outputs of JSON which will be
done for the next one so that's how you
got tied together and then the expected
entry Queen is just a function family so
you can have other functions defined in
the file but main is the expected entry
point so we'll see you kind of a quick
live demo of this in action like I said
I'll be using IBM top functions which is
managed openness even really take these
and apply it to any circle as bought
from you one so it should like look and
feel very similar to a lot of the other
service platforms so for our example
we'll say beyond this image really cute
cut the image and we'll say that it's
getting uploaded to our cloud object
storage or database from a mobile app or
UI and we want to react to this upload
right handsome coat so in our case maybe
we'll want to use some image analysis so
what's actually in that image so if we
upload this really cute puppy picture we
want to see some output like Bernese
Mountain Dog or dog or animal so this is
an architecture diagram for how we might
create something like this
when there's a new image URL that's
uploaded into the database that should
trigger an action to get run in this
case I divided that action into two
separate functions so one function is
responsible for reading the changes that
occur to the database that's the rate
changes from DB action and then that
action will parse the changes output the
URL to a new image in the database and
then hand that Europe URL off to the
attacks action so then they get tags
action will actually make you call out
to a visual recognition service do some
personal return value and hopefully
output what it believes is in our image
so this is a really simple use case but
you could definitely continue building
on this right you could save tags back
into the database you could add an
action for compressing a really large
that magic fees are up with something to
arch you can do things like handling
video uploads by creating another
function that breaks apart the video
into multiple frames and then running
the get tags on each frame and that
would be able to scale up kind of
independently each on a function is get
scaling out of the box so I don't have
to do anything special so let's check
this out this is going to be alive so
either surprise
so this is just our gift tags actions
that I talked about earlier should look
super familiar just some Python code
that we have and I'm gonna kind of walk
through a couple pieces of it so the
first thing that's happening is we're
gonna pull in this visual recognition
SDK so what that should imply to you is
is that visual recognition SDKs is
provided as a part of the runtime so
it's just already there in the runtime
and then we're gonna do a couple of
things I need to instantiate that with
an API key and a version number the API
key will actually pull in from
parameters for this action so we should
be able to pass any parameters into our
options in this particular case that guy
key doesn't change so I can actually
store it as a store parameter for this
particular action so if we click on
parameters you see okay I've got this
API key that's stored in here and it'll
just be safe for that action I'll make
sure everybody that right after this and
then the next thing is that we'll want
to pass in an image URL so that's the
image that we want to get the Travis for
and then finally we'll make a call out
to that visual recognition classifying
right here and then we'll just do a
little bit of per scene they were
terminated because I
go in there that we don't care about and
then we'll run all the time so let's try
that out
this is our little puppy picture cute
and if we do change input we can go in
here and make sure we have that image in
there and it is so you can click up like
so we're cutting this in as a predator
and if we click into though we should
hopefully see yes so we see some tags
back so it says puppy dog Labrador
Retriever dog treat the dog golden
retriever dog so just some different
tags of what the visual recognition
service thinks is in that image but
that's not all we wanted to do we
actually said we want to react to the
image when there's a new image or the
database right so let's see how we set
that up this is inside of a sequence and
that sequence contains two actions so
there's no read from database in action
and then there's they get tax action and
so the sequence gets kicked off by a
trigger so if we can grab connected
triggers we can see okay there's this
cloud image trigger so anytime a new
item gets out into the Sonic database
then not sugar will be fired so let's
try that out really quick so I'll grab
this image and then I already have
taught it open I want to log in again
so you can see I already have been a
database created upon my image URLs I
can create a new document in here so
just gonna create image URL I'm trying
to fly it's about five minutes left and
then I'll just like create document and
then what that's going to do hopefully
is cause my trigger to fire which will
then kick off that sequence the first
action was to read from the cloud
database whatever changes happen and
then the second action was to get the
tax so if we go over here hopefully we
should see that it was calling yeah and
so at 11 o'clock we can see it is there
but we can see that the trigger was
fired at 11 there was a sequence that
was called and the read option and then
they get tax action and each action has
an activation ID associated with it so
if we click that activation ieaf now we
should be able to see the results and
there so we have the logs just they're
printing out and then of course the
various tax that's just a little bit
actually yeah that worked at live demo
always get nervous don't let me stop you
okay perfect so I don't too much time
left but I didn't want to quickly
highlight I wanted to highlight one of
the pipeline specific libraries that's
out there I'm Scott Pyron so what it
does now is this school of making a
really easy push to fob experience for
Python developers so maybe if you have
like a super parallel workload and a
parallel workload is something where you
have little or no effort that's needed
to kind of separate the problem into
these number of parallel tasks so common
examples might be like 3d video
rendering pick up a GPU where you want
to run some code for each frame or maybe
for each pixel if you're doing the ray
tracing and those can all be handled
without any interdependency between them
so pi renesis library where you can take
your Python workloads scale it out into
multiple functions to be run on a
service platform so really their goal
like I said is a simple if I push the
cloud experience and you can run your
algorithm against the cluster of
machines without meaning to figure out
like how do I set that up or how do I
have those machines to talk to each
other how do I get the results back
hiren was if it's originally built for
Amazon Lambchop
also available for identical functions
so they'll check out this article to
learn a little bit more talked about
using tyrant for scenarios where you
have a lot of data processing to do and
the two examples they talked about were
really large data sets like solar flares
which can help protect storms they can
hamper power or satellite operations and
then they also charge about just the
sheer volume of data when looking at
like how neurons combining to create
behaviors or disease or cognition and
their their big goal is to really easily
give access to parallel computing to
data scientists and others there's
another article you can check out and
like I said it's built for Amazon the
event has recently been ported to IDM
top functions so this article is about
using pyrin for running stock market
predictions through the money Carlo
method so it uses pyrin to scale out and
then combine the results from those
simultaneously learning predictions so
that's all I had just a couple of quick
notes you can go to check out I get
caught much the first link and then the
last link is for the Apache openness
project so they're looking for a new
open source project to be a contributor
on it's a really fun one the community
is really nice so that's all
you
[Applause]